[Música]
i
o tópico mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer este ano trazer aqui
que eu queria inspirado na arma que o
button sendo que a marca francesa e as
caminhadas para mais de 60 elásticos e
ficava no alto e muito você não tem paz
em casa e também fazendo lembrar que
toda a gente possa fazer que é quando
aqui uma manivela
agora vocês quiserem subir esta arma
decorar um bolo automática ou seja
qualquer ganho líquido
fui deitar nos vêem como funciona aqui
um mecanismo da capa 47 que quando você
quer um tempo pequeno produtor que está
em dívida e puxou ficar cada um todo
incluindo uma segunda mãe dela e agora
vamos cuidar do brasil passo a passo
[Música]
acho
é
[Música]
a casa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
não
o cantor
[Música]
o
ah
[Música]
assim
ele
[Música]
an
o motor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
ah
ele
[Música]
é
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o o ó
o confronto
[Música]
não foi feito
a campanha
[Música]
to
é
o
[Música]
hoje eu vou
an
eu
[Música]
o
o próximo desafio será que vocês tenham
gostado desse projeto tanto quanto eu
gostei e ir embora que estava escrito
lutar por uma coisa que é o único golo
de tchô está boa e estou lá uma das
teorias então vocês quiserem votar em
mim basta clicar
pode ser que mais clique aqui depois
clique em votar por enquanto por lá
quatro fãs e se for a voz a opção clique
é invulgar ela imitamos o paulo sousa
purificado e desvia eo em um time tão
estrutura íamos nos conhecemos todo time
colombiano
isso é para que o marido estava porque
não faço ilação então estavam muito ver
um estudioso sério e mostrar também as
animações que o fato e falar em moções
estava bastante o tempo é uma em matão
foi que eu amo vocês querem convidar ver
podem clicar aqui em cima sem dó
esperado no costão da uma coisa que
todos nos comentários
eu tento sempre fazer